so I took two shots of the Pfizer
vaccine I had zero symptoms wow so and I
was wondering well see but that's my
feelings right this is not because I I
felt fine I was waiting did you have
pain at the injection site
uh no it was kind of pleasant you felt
nothing the next day no nothing okay no
no no tightness no exhaustion no
uh but see like have an insane sleeping
schedule I already put myself through
crazy stuff that said maybe I was
expecting something really bad like I
was way and therefore didn't feel it
then but I also got um
allergy shots
and those I was out all next day like
exhausted for some reason so that that
gave me like a sense like okay at least
sometimes I can feel shitty that's good
to know sure and then then in the
vaccine it didn't but the the question
is like how much does my mind come into
play there or the expectations of
symptoms uh the expectations of not
feeling well how does that affect the
sort of the self-reporting the symptoms
I think it's definitely a variable there
but there's certainly many people that
don't feel anything after the vaccines
and there's some that have a whole range
of of things like soreness and fever Etc